one of the most surprising things I
think that people learn when you study
perception and you look at the research
is that we can be influenced as
perceivers by stereotypes that we don't
even believe are true so you don't have
to be racist or or be a chauvinist or be
any any kind of a bad person to be
influenced by stereotypes it turns out
all you need to do is know the
stereotype to be influenced by it
stereotypes really are an example of
categorization brains are have evolved
human brains have evolved to be very
rapid categorizes of things it's what
allows us to interact with our world so
smoothly and effectively right so you
can go into a room and see a chair for
the first time and you know that it's
for sitting and not for eating or
climbing because you identify it as a
member of the category chair stereotypes
are categories of people and sometimes
they're actually very helpful so we have
stereotypes of what police officers or
librarians or nurses are like and those
stereotypes allow us to fill in the
blanks a little bit and know without
even talking to a member of that
profession something about what their
job is how I'm supposed to interact with
them what it's reasonable to ask of them
you know how our interaction is probably
gonna go the problem of course is that
every stereotype is a generalization the
does never applies completely accurately
to any one person and sometimes
stereotypes are just flat-out wrong
there they're just they're just
absolutely unnecessarily negative and
completely untrue and yet we are
affected by them because again that's
one of these fees one perception things
that that the activation of stereotypes
in the mind is odd relatively automatic
for example I'm a female scientist and
there are stereotypes about women not
being is capable in science and
mathematics so I like to get right out
in front with people and you know show
them demonstrate my expertise in science
and math and so that that I can counter
that stereotype before it has a chance
to negatively affect their view of me
particularly when the perceiver isn't
really mode
to be accurate about you or is only
getting really a kind of a quick glimpse
of you and they're really kind of busy
thinking about other things that's when
all of these things are at they're sort
of the highest danger of influencing and
getting in the way of being seen the way
you really want to so as as the person
who's being perceived really what you
want to be able to do is get that other
person to really want to see you
accurately the the best way to do that
are to get that person to work with you
in some way or to get that person to to
to to notice that you can help them
reach their goals that's another really
great way to get people to to kind of
get past the initial assumptions and
really take a second look at you
so be someone who's instrumental in
helping other people reach their goals
and they're going to be much more likely
to try to see the real you